[Music]
this guy growth and deep is somewhat of
a mathematical Idol to me and I just
love this quote don't you too often in
math we dive into showing that a certain
fact is true with the long series of
formulas before stepping back and making
sure that it feels reasonable and
preferably obvious at least at an
intuitive level in this video I want to
talk about integrals and the thing that
I want to become almost obvious is that
they are an inverse of derivatives here
we're just going to focus on one example
which is a kind of dual to the example
of a moving car that I talked about in
Chapter two of the series introducing
derivatives then in the next video we're
going to see how the same idea
generalizes but to a couple other
contacts imagine that you're sitting in
a car and you can't see out the window
all you see is the speedometer at some
point the car starts moving speeds up
and then slows back down to a stop all
over the course of eight seconds the
question is is there a nice way to
figure out how far you've traveled
during that time based only on your view
of the speedometer or better yet can you
find a distance function S of T that
tells you how far you've traveled after
a given amount of time T somewhere
between zero and eight seconds let's say
that you take note of the velocity at
every second and you make a plot over
time that looks something like this
and maybe you find that a nice function
to model that velocity over time in
meters per second is V of T equals T
times 8 minus T you might remember in
Chapter two of the series we were
looking at the opposite situation where
you knew what a distance function was s
of T and he wanted to figure out the
velocity function from that there I
showed how the derivative of a distance
versus time function gives you a
velocity versus time function so in our
current situation where all we know is
velocity it should make sense that
finding a distance first time function
is going to come down to asking what
function has a derivative of T times 8
minus T this is often described as
finding the antiderivative of a function
and indeed that's what we'll end up
doing and you could even pause right now
and try that but first I want to spend
the bulk of this video showing how this
question is related to finding the area
bounded by the velocity graph because
that helps to build an intuition for a
whole class of problems things called
integral problems in math and science to
start off
notice that this question would be a lot
easier if the car was just moving at a
constant velocity right in that case you
could just multiply the velocity in
meters per second times the amount of
time that has passed in seconds and that
would give you the number of meters
traveled and notice you can visualize
that product that distance as an area
and if visualising distance as area
seems kind of weird I'm right there with
you it's just that on this plot where
the horizontal Direction has units of
seconds and the vertical Direction has
units of meters per second units of area
just very naturally correspond to meters
but what makes our situation hard is
that velocity is not constant its
incessantly changing at every single
instant
it would even be a lot easier if it only
ever changed at a handful of points
maybe stayin static for the first second
and then suddenly discontinuously
jumping to a constant 7 m/s for the next
second and so on with discontinuous
jumps to portions of constant velocity
that would make it uncomfortable for the
driver in fact it's actually physically
impossible but it would make your
calculations a lot more straightforward
you could just compute the distance
traveled on each interval by multiplying
the constant velocity on that interval
by the change in time and then just add
all of those up so what we're going to
do is approximate the velocity function
as if it was constant on a bunch of
intervals and then as is common in
calculus we'll see how refining that
approximation leads us to something more
precise
here let's make this a little more
concrete by throwing in some numbers
chop up the time axis between zero and
eight seconds into many small intervals
each with some little width DT something
like 0.25 seconds now consider one of
those intervals like the one between t
equals 1 and 1.25 in reality the car
speeds up from 7 meters per second to
about 8.4 m/s during that time and you
could find those numbers just by
plugging in T equals 1 and T equals 1.25
- the equation for velocity what we want
to do is approximate the cars motion as
if its velocity was constant on that
interval again the reason for doing that
is we just don't really know how to
handle situations other than constant
velocity ones
you could choose this constant to be
anything between seven and eight point
four it actually doesn't matter all that
matters is that our sequence of
approximations whatever they are gets
better and better as DT gets smaller and
smaller the treating this cars journey
as a bunch of discontinuous jumps and
speed between portions of constant
velocity becomes a less wrong reflection
of reality as we decrease the time
between those jumps
so for convenience on an interval like
this let's just approximate the speed
with whatever the true cars velocity is
at the start of that interval the height
of the graph above the left side which
in this case is 7 so in this example
interval according to our approximation
the car moves 7 meters per second times
0.25 seconds that's 1.75 meters and it's
nicely visualized as the area of this
thin rectangle in truth that's a little
under the real distance traveled but not
by much and the same goes for every
other interval the approximated distance
is V of T times DT it's just that you'd
be plugging in a different value for T
at each one of these giving a different
height for each rectangle
I'm going to write out an expression for
the sum of the areas of all those
rectangles in kind of a funny way take
this symbol here which looks like a
stretched s4 sum and then put a zero at
its bottom and 1/8 at its top to
indicate that will be ranging over time
steps between 0 and 8 seconds and as I
said the amount we're adding up at each
time step is V of T times DT 2 things
are implicit in this notation first of
all that value DT plays two separate
roles not only is it a factor in each
quantity that we're adding up it also
indicates the spacing between each
sample time step so when you make DT
smaller and smaller even though it
decreases the area of each rectangle it
increases the total number of rectangles
whose areas were adding up because if
they're thinner it takes more of them to
fill that space and second the reason we
don't use the usual Sigma notation to
indicate a sum is that this expression
it's technically not any particular sum
for any particular choice of DT it's
meant to express whatever that sum
approaches as DT approaches zero and as
you can see what that approaches is the
area bounded by this curve and the
horizontal axis remember smaller choices
of DT indicate closer approximations for
the original question how far does the
car actually go so this limiting value
for the sum the area under this curve
gives us the precise answer to the
question in full-on approximated
precision now tell me that's not
surprising we had this pretty
complicated idea of approximations that
can involve adding up a huge number of
very tiny things and yet the value that
those approximations approach can be
described so simply it's just the area
underneath this curve
this expression is called an integral of
V of T since it brings all of its values
together it integrates them now at this
point you could say how does this help
you've just reframed one hard question
finding how far the car has traveled
into an equally hard problem finding the
area between this graph and the
horizontal axis and you'd be right if
the velocity distance duo was the only
thing that we cared about most of this
video with all of the area under a curve
nonsense
would be a waste of time we could just
skip straight ahead to finding an
antiderivative but finding the area
between a functions graph and the
horizontal axis is somewhat of a common
language for many disparate problems
that can be broken down and approximated
as the sum of a large number of small
things you'll see more in the next video
but for now I'll just say in the
abstract that understanding how to
interpret and how to compute the area
under a graph is a very general
problem-solving tool in fact the first
video of this series already covered the
basics of how this works but now that we
have more of a background with
derivatives we can actually take this
idea to its completion for a velocity
example think of this right endpoint as
a variable capital T
we're thinking of this integral of the
velocity function between zero and T the
area under this curve between those
inputs as a function where the upper
bound is the variable that area
represents the distance the car has
traveled after T seconds right so in
reality this is a distance versus time
function S of T now ask yourself what is
the derivative of that function on the
one hand a tiny change in distance over
a tiny change in time
that's velocity that is what velocity
means but there's another way to see
this purely in terms of this graph and
this area which generalizes a lot better
to other integral problems a slight
nudge of DT to the input causes that
area to increase some little D s
represented by the area of this sliver
the height of that sliver is the height
of the graph at that point V of T and
its width is DT and for small enough DT
we can basically consider that sliver to
be a rectangle so this little bit of
added area D s is approximately equal to
V of T times DT and because that's an
approximation that gets better and
better for smaller DT the derivative of
that area function D s DT at this point
equals VT the value of the velocity
function at whatever time we started on
and that right there that's a super
general argument the derivative of any
function giving the area under a graph
like this is equal to the function for
the graph itself
so if our velocity function is T times 8
minus T what should s be what function
of T has a derivative of T times 8 minus
T
it's easier to see if we expand this out
writing it as eight t minus T squared
and then we can just take each part one
at a time what function has a derivative
of eight times T well we know that the
derivative of T squared is two T so if
we just scale that up by a factor of
four we can see that the derivative of
four T squared is eight T and for that
second part what kind of function do you
think might have negative T squared as a
derivative well using the power rule
again we know that the derivative of a
cubic term T cubed gives us a square
term 3t squared so if we just scale that
down by a third the derivative of one
third T cubed is exactly T squared and
then making that negative you see that
negative one third T cubed has a
derivative of negative T squared
therefore the antiderivative of our
function eight t minus T squared is four
T squared minus one third T cubed but
there's a slight issue here we could add
any constant we want to this function
and it's derivative is still going to be
eight t minus T squared the derivative
of a constant just always goes to zero
and if you were to graph s of T you
could think of this in the sense that
moving a graph of a distance function up
and down does nothing to affect its
slope at every input so in reality
there's actually infinitely many
different possible antiderivative
functions and every one of them looks
like 4 T squared minus 1/3 T cubed plus
C for some constant C but there is one
piece of information that we haven't
used yet that's going to let us zero in
on which antiderivative to use the lower
bound of the integral this integral has
to be zero when we drag that right
endpoint all the way to the left
endpoint right the distance travelled by
the car between zero seconds and zero
seconds is well zero so as we found the
area as a function of capital T is an
antiderivative for the stuff inside and
to choose what constant to add to this
expression what you do is subtract
off the value of that antiderivative
function at the lower bound if you think
about it for a moment that ensures that
the integral from the lower bound to
itself will indeed be zero as it so
happens when you evaluate the function
we have right here at T equals zero you
get zero so in this specific case you
actually don't need to subtract anything
off for example the total distance
traveled during the full eight seconds
is this expression evaluated at T equals
eight which is about eighty five point
three three minus zero so the answer as
a whole is just eighty five point three
three but a more typical example would
be something like the integral between
one and seven that's the area pictured
right here and it represents the
distance traveled between one second and
seven seconds
what you do is evaluate the
antiderivative we found at the top bound
seven and then subtract off its value at
that bottom bound one and notice by the
way it doesn't matter which
antiderivative we chose here if for some
reason it had a constant added to it
like five that constant would just
cancel out
more generally anytime you want to
integrate some function and remember you
think of that as adding up values f of x
times DX for inputs in a certain range
and then asking what is that some
approach as DX approaches zero the first
step to evaluating that integral is to
find an antiderivative some other
function capital F whose derivative is
the thing inside the integral then the
integral equals this antiderivative
evaluated at the top bound - its value
at the bottom bound and this fact right
here that you're staring at is the
fundamental theorem of calculus and I
want you to appreciate something kind of
crazy about this fact the integral the
limiting value for the sum of all of
these thin rectangles takes into account
every single input on the continuum from
the lower bound to the upper bound
that's why we use the word integrate it
brings them all together and yet to
actually compute it using an
antiderivative you only look at two
inputs the top bound and the bottom
bound it almost feels like cheating
finding the antiderivative implicitly
accounts for all of the information
needed to add up the values between
those two bounds that's just crazy to me
this idea is deep and there's a lot
packed into this whole concept so let's
just recap everything that just happened
shall we we wanted to figure out how far
a car goes just by looking at the
speedometer and what makes that hard is
that velocity is always changing if you
approximate velocity to be constant on
multiple different intervals you could
figure out how far the car goes on each
interval just with multiplication and
then add all of those up better and
better approximations for the original
problem
correspond to collections of rectangles
whose aggregate area is closer and
closer to being the area under this
curve between the start time and the end
time so that area under the curve is
actually the precise distance traveled
for the true nowhere constant velocity
function if you think of that area as a
function itself with a variable right
endpoint you can deduce that the
derivative of that area function must
equal the height of the graph at every
point and that's really the key right
there it means that to find a function
giving this area you ask what function
has V of T as a derivative there are
actually infinitely many anti
derivatives of a given function since
you can always just add some constant
without affecting the derivative so you
account for that by subtracting off the
value of whatever antiderivative
function you choose at the bottom bound
by the way one important thing to bring
up before we leave is the idea of
negative area what if the velocity
function was negative at some point
meaning the car goes backwards it's
still true that a tiny distance traveled
D s on a little time interval is about
equal to the velocity at that time
multiplied by the tiny change in time
it's just that the number you'd plug in
for velocity would be negative so the
tiny change in distance is negative in
terms of our thin rectangles if a
rectangle goes below the horizontal axis
like this its area represents a bit of
distance traveled backwards so if what
you want in the end is to find a
distance between the cars start point
and its end point this is something
you're going to want to subtract and
that's generally true of integrals
whenever a graph dips below the
horizontal axis the area between that
portion of the graph and the horizontal
axis is counted as negative and what
you'll commonly hear is that integrals
don't measure area per se they measure
the signed area between the graph and
the horizontal axis
next up I'm going to bring up more
context where this idea of an integral
and area under curves comes up along
with some other intuitions for this
fundamental theorem of calculus
maybe you remember chapter 2 of this
series introducing the derivative was
sponsored by the art of problem-solving
so I think there's something elegant to
the fact that this video which is kind
of a dual to that one was also supported
in part by the art of problem solving I
really can't imagine a better sponsor
for this channel because it's a company
whose books and whose courses I
recommend to people anyway they were
highly influential to me when I was a
student developing a love for creative
math so if you're a parent looking to
foster your own child's love for the
subject or if you're a student who wants
to see what math has to offer beyond
rote schoolwork I cannot recommend the
art of problem-solving enough whether
that's their newest development to build
the right intuitions and elementary
school kids called beast Academy or
their courses in higher-level topics and
contest preparation going to a o-p-s
comm slash three blue one brown or
clicking on the link in the description
lets them know that you came from this
channel which may encourage them to
support future projects like this one I
consider these videos a success not when
they teach people a particular bit of
math which can only ever be a drop in
the ocean but when they encourage people
to go and explore that expanse for
themselves and the art of
problem-solving is among the few great
places to actually do that exploration
[Music]
[Music]
you